- [Women] Do you know how
many kids feel less than
because they didn't have a
chance to go to school?
They're not this,
they're not that.
And then you look at
someone like GaryVee
and he admits,
he says in public that
he got D's and F's.
And look at where he is now.
Do you know what kind
of hope that creates?
- It's a long game. I was
told between seven years old
and 18 years old that I lost.
That I was a loser because
this is what I got.
F City, baby. But when I
saw F City I knew inside
that this was not the game
that I was gonna play.
I was patient. I ate crow
in that 12 year period
while the market and the machine
told me I wasn't gonna win.
I knew what my outcome was and
you may now be in your 20s
and 30s and 40s and the machine
the marketplace might be
telling you that you're going to lose
but it is about
staying the course and
putting in the work and
positioning yourself
in the right position to
go out and win.